argenteuil bonjour merci soit avec nous
alors un discours prononcé devant les
instances du parti républicain plutôt
insultant quand même en tout cas très
offensif peut-il laisser des traces à ce
qu'il marque le grand retour de donald
trump donald trump n'est jamais parti
vous vous souvenez que à la fois il a eu
du mal à quitter la maison blanche il a
eu du mal à reconnaître sa défaite
il est il s'est un peu de terreau et
dans sa superbe résidence de floride
mais en réalité il n'a jamais caché ses
intentions son intention c'est de
continuer le combat il a dit très
récemment il va continuer le combat
alors sur sa route
évidemment il y avait démocrates en
force il ya la nouvelle administration
mais il ya surtout le sort du parti
républicain il souhaite évidemment faire
main basse sur le parti républicain
parce que même si une base électorale
absolument importante que j'évalue à au
moins un tiers de l'électorat qui a voté
pour lui au moins un tiers des 74
millions de voix qui se sont portées sur
son nom
eh bien il sait qu'il aura besoin à la
fois des lui qu'il aura besoin d'un
parti et il veut absolument chasser
j'ai envie de dire il n'est qu'un site
les notables du parti républicain donc
il s'en prend tout d'abord à à l'ancien
chef ancien leader des républicains au
sénat je rappelle que c'est aussi
l'époux de l'ancien ministre de donald
trump qui elle même avait démissionné un
peu après l'atteinte du capital donc on
voit bien que donald trump essaie de se
débarrasser d'un certain nombre de
dirigeants du parti républicain en
particulier les plus anciens
et lorsqu'ils entendent assurer les
futurs candidats en leur disant si vous
voulez être élu ou réélu lors du
prochain scrutin de mi-mandat alors
rejoignez nous rejoignez moi donc c'est
un véritable bras de force qui s'ouvre
est donc pour moi ça laissera sais c'est
pas simplement laisser des traces mais
il part en guerre contre les
responsables du parti et c'est
probablement une démarche politique
étatique bien pensé avec l'objectif
jean-claude beaujour 2000
24 eh bien je pense que le premier
objectif c'est de gagner les élections
mi-mandat
deuxième objectif de se positionner
comme le véritable opposant de joe de
joe madden de manière à apparaître comme
le candidat naturel de la droite
républicaine lors du prochain scout est
naturellement tout ça est encore bien
loin il y a encore beaucoup de dents
d'embûches sur le chemin du futur
candidat quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs mais
en tout état cause les choses sont
rythmées pour être pour s'organiser si
besoin comme cela alors la crise
sanitaire également d'un autre homme
s'attribuent le mérite du vaccin il
insulte au passage le docteur fois aussi
le conseiller médical en chef de la
présidence
rien n'aura finalement mais s'est
dirigée contre joe biden qui aurait pris
deux cols relais oui alors là on n'est
pas surpris
alors évidemment il a le la
caractéristique de l'ancien président
des états unis c'est de forcer le trait
vous imaginer que les hommes politiques
font très souvent cela en réalité il se
rend bien compte qu'il a pris le train
un peu en retard sur cette histoire de
coronavirus qu'en réalité je m'adonne à
milan semble aaa fait de la crise
sanitaire un axe de campagne faure et
qu'aujourd'hui
ben 185 millions au moment je m'exprime
187 millions d'américains ont été
vaccinées 3 millions d'américains sont
vaccinés tous les jours et en principe
si tout se passe bien
50% la population ne sera le 9 mai et
fin juin 75 % de la population
donc il y aura une immunité collective
aux états unis aux alentours du début
juillet ce qui veut dire que le pays va
pouvoir repartir économique pas donc il
est évident que donald trump ne veut pas
perdre un petit bout de ce qu'ils
pourraient s que humainement on peut
considérer comme une victoire pour les
républicains parce que les démocrates
pardon pour l'administration baden c'est
pas simplement une victoire politique
mais c'est une victoire économique
sociale parce que
peuple américain souffre beaucoup de
cette crise sanitaire et donc joe biden
entend entendra sans aucun doute tirer
largement profit de ceux de sa démarche
et donald trump n'a pas envie d'être en
reste par rapport à ce sujet
certainement pas envie d'être en reste
qu il pense même à créer son vaccin
donald trump top trumps in apparemment
quand était que cette idée aux états
unis ccc crédible alors je vous
répondrai à la fois il ya deux angles de
réponses possibles ya l'angle
scientifique et puis y'a rien l'angle
politique l'angle scientifique mais
seuls les scientifiques peux vous dire
où en sont et éventuellement ses équipes
sur de la recherche on ne crée pas un
vaccin comme cela je ne sais pas qui
l'ancien président des états unis a
derrière lui pour pouvoir faire de la
recherche créer un vaccin
et puis subir les tests qui existe aux
etats-unis de 2 à des formules
différentes de mise sur le marché ces
terrains en tout état de cause sur le
plan sur le plan politique il est il est
certain qu'il ya une petite minorité de
supporters de donald trump qui de toutes
les façons vous diront que vous diront
que donald trump est capable de tout et
qui le croiront à côté de cela vous avez
le reste de l'amérique qui pour laquelle
c'est beaucoup moins la préoccupation la
paire préoccupation je vais vous dire
sur le terrain
la préoccupation des américains ce n'est
plus tellement la bataille donald trump
show by then parce que cela s'est
terminé aujourd'hui nos nounous
concitoyens américaines ont une
préoccupation les américains ont une
préoccupation c'est la possibilité de
pouvoir recommencer à travailler c'est
la possibilité de pouvoir payer leurs
dettes n'oubliez pas qu'il ya des
risques
c'est la possibilité de pouvoir se
soigner pour ceux qui sont ceux qui sont
malades est atteinte du virus
et pour cela vous savez très bien qu'il
y assiste
social - protecteur qu'en europe donc je
pense que c'est là aujourd'hui
là où se trouve la place la
préoccupation de l'américain moyen
le reste est relativement marginale
merci jean tavaux jour d'avoir été avec
nous nous avoir apporté votre analyse et
c'est là